First of all, let's run our app once so
we can call the preload data method
that deletes all the previous
contents of the database, and
then populates it with notebooks and
nodes.
And here we have our preloaded data.
So let's go to app delegate.
And let's comment it out.
As we don't need this anymore, we can
create objects using the app's UI.
So let's comment out pre-load data.
And now, let's go back to the model and
make some modifications.
Let's create a new entity for photo
frame with an image data attribute.
We can't save the image
as an instance of UI
image because core data has
no idea what a UI image is.
So we have to save it as a binary
type which means [INAUDIBLE].
It's a bit inconvenient but
we'll deal with it later.
Every single note will
have a photo frame and
each photo frame might
have a single image data.
This property is going to be
optional as it could be empty but
every note will have an image data.
So now we have to create
the relationships between note and
photo free.
It can't be optional because every
note must have a photo so off it goes.
And the deletion rule should be when we
delete a node, we delete the PhotoFrame.
So it should be Cascade.
Now let's go back to PhotoFrame and
create the inverse relationship.
This should not be optional
because a photo frame
should not exist if it's
not connected to a note.
And when we delete a photo frame,
what should we do to the note?
Nothing so nullify.
Okay so let's save and
run our app and see what happens and
it looks like we have an error and
this is the reason.
The model used to open
the store is incompatible
with the one used to create this store.
Well we got this error because
we already have saved objects
that match the previous data model,
the one that didn't have a photo frame.
Now we changed this model but
we forgot to tell core data how to
migrate the older data to the new form.
Fortunately, this is quite easy.
So think about it and
make sure you can't reproduce this on
your own project and we'll fix it.